EVERYONE.
WE WANT IF WE HAD ONLY KNOWN.
FOR THE PRESIDENT AS DESCRIBED
IN HIM AS A PERSONAL FRIEND AND
PRAISED CHINA’S ACTIONS EARLY ON
ON.
>> DO YOU BELIEVE THAT CHINA IS
INFLICTING THIS UPON OUR
COUNTRY?
>> NO, I DON’T BELIEVE THAT.
THEY COULD’VE GOTTEN US A LOT
LOT EARLIER NOTICE, ABSOLUTELY.
>> MR. PRESIDENT , YOUR
CREDIBILITY RATINGS ARE VERY LOW
LOW.
>> WHO ARE YOU ASKING THAT
QUESTION TOO?
BECAUSE I SEE THAT THEY ARE VERY
HIGH.
95% OF THE REPUBLICAN PARTY.
>> Shannon: VERY COMPETITIVE
IN THE PRESS MEETINGS.
GOOD TO HAVE YOU WITH US.
>> GREAT TO BE WITH YOU SHANNON.
>> Shannon: LET’S START WITH
TALKING ABOUT CHINA.
CHINA TURNED FOCUSED OUTWARD.
THEY ARE REACHING OUT TO OTHER
COUNTRIES.
DWINDLING INTO THE SINGLE
DIGITS, CHINA IS NOT GETTING A
DIPLOMATIC OFFENSE TO HELP.
THEY ARE GIVING CHINA THE CHANCE
TO REPOSITION THEMSELVES AS A
RESPONSIBLE, LOCAL GLOBAL LEADER
IS THAT GOING TO FLY?
>> I DON’T THINK SO.
HOUSE INTELLIGENCE HAVE HAD A
LONG-RUNNING INVESTIGATION INTO
CHINA.
AND WHAT YOU ARE BEGINNING TO
SEE IS WHAT WE HAVE BEEN SEEING
FOR MANY YEARS.
THIS IS A NUN FOR A TERRIEN
REGIME THAT CANNOT BE TRUSTED.
ONE OF THE MOST IMPORTANT THINGS
THAT WE NEED RIGHT HERE, IT
WOULD BE NICE TO HAVE GOOD DATA.
ABOUT HOW THEY TESTED, WHAT WERE
THE SYMPTOMS, WHAT WERE THE
DIFFERENT AGE GROUPS.
AND WHAT WERE THE SYMPTOMS THAT
THEY CAME UP WITH?
WHAT WERE THE BEST TREATMENTS?
THESE ARE ALL THINGS THAT YOU
ARE NOT SEEING.
YOU ARE SEEING THEM BLAME THE
U.S. ARMY.
THAT IS UNACCEPTABLE.
THIS VIRUS ORIGINATED IN CHINA.
THEY COVERED IT UP.
AND THEY HAVE CONNED A WORLDWIDE
PANIC.
>> Shannon: TONIGHT, EARLIER
ON TUCKER, THEY TALKED ABOUT
INTRODUCING LEGISLATION TO BREAK
THE U.S. DEPENDENCE ON
PHARMACEUTICALS THAT CHINA IS
NOW DANGLING OVER OUR HEADS.
WEIGHTY THICK ECHOES?
>> WELL, LOOK, I THINK WHAT YOU
ARE GOING TO SEE AFTER WE FIGURE
OUT HOW TO TREAT THIS VIRUS AND
HOPEFULLY IT BEGINS TO SLOW
GLOBALLY, WHAT YOU ARE GOING TO
SEE HIS MANY COUNTRIES ARE GOING
TO WANT TO BREAK THE SUPPLY
CHAIN.
WE ARE NOT GOING TO WANT TO HAVE
TO RELY ON CHINA FOR ANYTHING
THAT IS PARAMOUNT OF THE
SURVIVAL OF OUR PEOPLE OR FOR
OUR ECONOMY.
WE HAD ALREADY STARTED THAT,
SOME OF THE TRADE SANCTIONS THAT
WE PUT IN PLACE AND THE TRADE
TARIFFS THAT THE TRUMP
ADMINISTRATION WAS DEALING WITH.
NOW I THINK PEOPLE ARE BEGINNING
TO UNDERSTAND THAT IT’S NOT JUST
ABOUT THE SUPPLY CHAIN, IT’S NOT
JUST ABOUT THERE ARE 2025 AND
2035 PLAN TO RULE THE WORLD.
YOU ALSO HAVE OTHER ISSUES.
LIKE HOW THEY ARE SUBSIDIZING
AND TRYING TO ROLL OUT THE NEXT
GENERATION OF COMMUNICATIONS
CAPABILITIES.
AND ALSO HOW THEY ARE STEALING
US BLIND WITH OUR INTELLECTUAL
PROPERTY.
THESE ARE ALL ISSUES THAT HAVE
TO STOP.
YOU’RE GOING OUT TO SEE MAJOR
PIECES OF LEGISLATION THAT ARE
GOING TO BEGIN TO MOVE AND
ULTIMATELY BECOME LAW TO RAIN
AND A WILD AND OUT OF AND OUT OF
CONTROL AUTHORITARIAN REGIME.
>> Shannon: WE ARE CHANGING
OUR PROJECTION, OUR IDEAS EVERY
SINGLE DAY BECAUSE WE ARE
GETTING SO MUCH NEW DATA IN.
WITHOUT A MIND, I WANT TO TAKE
YOU TO SUNDAY NIGHT WHEN YOU
SAID FOLKS SHOULD TRY TO GO OUT
AND GO TO LOCAL BUSINESSES.
THERE IS NO BEEN A VERY STRICT
CRACKDOWN ON ALL KINDS OF
THINGS, BARS AND RESTAURANTS
CLOSED EVERYWHERE.
I WANT TO GIVE YOU A CHANCE TO
ANSWER YOUR CRITICS.
>> YEAH, THAT’S A TOTAL FAKE
NEWS.
ONCE AGAIN.
WHAT I SAID STILL REMAINS THE
CASE.
IT IS STILL TRUE.
RIGHT NOW, WHAT WE HAVE ON THE
GROUND HERE OUT IN CALIFORNIA,
THE NUMBER ONE PROBLEM WE HAVE
RIGHT NOW IS HUNDREDS AND
HUNDREDS OF PEOPLE THAT ARE
GOING INTO COSTCO AND GROCERY
STORES AND OTHER PLACES.
THAT’S EXACTLY WHAT WE DON’T
WANT YOU TO DO.
IN THE MEANTIME, WE HAVE
RESTAURANTS REMAINING OPEN.
THAT CAN SERVE FOOD SAFELY AND
CHEAPLY.
THEY ARE MOVING TO TAKE OUT, YOU
HAVE DRY FOODS.
ONCE AGAIN, THE FAKE NEWS MAKING
THIS VERY POLITICAL.
AND IT SHOWS WHAT LITTLE
CREDIBILITY THEY HAVE.
THEY HAVE NO CLUE.
IT’S FUN TO GET DRUNK AND SIT IN
YOUR EYE FREAKED HOW QUICK I’VE
SUBBED OUT TWEETS.
I DO SEE HUNDREDS OF PEOPLE IN
LINE WAITING IN LINE IN THE COLD
AND THE WET AND THE RAIN.
TRYING TO GET OLD PEOPLE, YOUNG
PEOPLE -- ALL SORTS OF AGES.
THIS IS NOT GOOD.
RIGHT NOW, WE HAVE RESTAURANTS
THAT ARE OPEN.
WHERE PEOPLE CAN GO GET FOOD.
>> Shannon: WOULD YOU SAY TO
PEOPLE NOT TO GO PLACES WHERE
THERE ARE DINING ROOMS OR OPEN
AREAS?
ARE YOU STRICTLY SAYING YOU CAN
PICK UP, BUT DON’T GO TO PLACES
WHERE YOU GOING TO SIT DOWN TO
BE NEXT TO PEOPLE.
>> I THINK MOST OF THE
RESTAURANTS NOW WOULD PREFER YOU
NOT TO DINE IN.
WHAT MOST FOLKS HAVE BEEN
RECOMMENDING IS THAT YOU WANT TO
KEEP US FACING AWAY.
YOU DON’T WANT TO BE IN LARGER
GROUPS OF TEN.
I THINK THAT’S THE BEST WAY TO
THINK ABOUT THIS.
BE SMART.
TRY TO PRACTICE SOCIAL
DISTANCING.
WHICH IS NOT WHAT IS HAPPENING
AT COSTCO AND TARGET AND GROCERY
STORES RIGHT NOW.
THE MEDIA, HOW THEY ACTUALLY
TAKEN TO HEART WHAT I SAID ON
SUNDAY, AND ACTUALLY TOLD PEOPLE
IN THIS COUNTRY THAT WE DO NOT
HAVE A FOOD SHORTAGE.
>> Shannon: WE DON’T WE DON’T.
>> STOP HOARDING THINGS.
GETS SAFE AND WARM FOOD.
>> Shannon: I WANT TO ASK YOU
REALLY QUICKLY, THIS IS NOW A
BIPARTISAN IMPACT FOR PEOPLE ON
THE HILL WHO HAVE TESTED
POSITIVE.
WILL YOU GET TESTED?
>> I DON’T KNOW IF I WILL BE
TESTED BECAUSE I THINK WE NEED
TO MAKE SURE THAT THE TESTS ARE
AVAILABLE FOR THOSE WHO REALLY
NEED THEM.
I DID JUST SPEAK TO A CLOSE
FRIEND OF MINE WHO IS RECOVERING
WELL.
HE SAID HE HAD SOME HIGH FEVER
OVER THE WEEKEND.
SHARP HEADACHE.
HAS A COUGH.
BUT IT FEELS PRETTY GOOD AND
WANTED EVERYONE TO KNOW THAT A
LOT OF PEOPLE CAN GET OVER THIS.
AND I STILL THINK THE NUMBER ONE
ISSUE THAT WE HAVE UP THERE
RIGHT NOW IS THAT IF YOU HAVE A
RESPIRATORY ISSUE AT ANY AGE,
YOU NEED TO BE VERY COMFORTABLE.
HE QUARANTINED HIMSELF BECAUSE
HE HAS FAMILY MEMBERS THAT HAVE
RESPIRATORY ISSUES.
THANK FULLY, HE DID THAT.
HE STAYED AWAY FROM HIS FAMILY
BECAUSE HE KNEW HE WAS AROUND A
LOT OF PEOPLE.
AND HE KNEW GETTING CLOSE TO
SOMEONE THAT HAD A RESPIRATORY
ISSUE COULD BE PROBLEMATIC.
AND HE MADE THE RIGHT CHOICE.
>> Shannon: WE ALL NEED TO
FOLLOW THOSE GUIDELINES.
AT 99.3% OF PEOPLE WILL RECOVER.
WE HAVE TO SHARE THAT MESSAGE AS